just like you I was once a student and
the truth is you can get really lazy to
cook for yourself especially when you're
living on your own during my first year
in you name I ate out almost every
single day and without realizing it I
started gaining weight
it wasn't until towards the end of my
second year where I started to learn to
cook for myself and Hey I had no idea
what I was doing so it was really basic
cooking but that got me back on a
healthy eating track and in fact that's
how I got into fitness so I'm gonna
share with you three of my favorite
student recipes which I still cook up
until today because it is super easy
with very little ingredients and you can
prep them in under 15 minutes first is
Jack a potato with tuna and melted
cheese the proper recipe calls for the
potato to be baked however to speed up
the process we're going to use in the
microwave only five ingredients 1 large
potato washed half a can of tuna chunks
2 tablespoons of shredded cheese 1 tbsp
of yogurt and about quarter teaspoon of
mixed herbs in fact if you are really
lazy you can use the first three
ingredients the first step is to prick
the potato all over with a knife then
cook the potato on full power in the
microwave for 7 to 10 minutes while the
potato is cooking makes the tuna chunks
yogurt and herps together then set it
aside after 10 minutes remove the potato
from the microwave and slice the potato
on the top fill it up with the tuna
mixture and I'm going to top it up with
a little bit of strategies place it back
in the microwave and cook very quickly
for about 1 and 1/2 minutes just to melt
the cheese dinner is ready and I'm
serving mine with a side of salad it is
that simple and this is a balanced meal
you're getting the cuts from the potato
protein from the tuna healthy fats from
the cheese and lots of vegetables so
once of impacts in about 337 calories
and this makes a very filling dinner or
lunch you can alternate the tuna with
chicken breast
beef big beans
or any other protein of your choice try
it out the next student meal is white
bean chicken soup this is a one pot dish
so it is as simple as dumping all the
ingredients into a pot and allow them to
cook so for my recipe I'm using one can
of white beans rinsed and drained when
chicken breast 2 onions 4 celery stalks
1 carrot 1 tomato about 4 cups of
chicken stock quarter teaspoon of mixed
herbs and salt and pepper to taste so
start by prepping all your ingredients
chop up all the vegetables the next step
is to simply fill up a pot with chicken
stock and add in all your ingredients so
I'm seasoning mine with a little bit of
mixed herbs and also salt and pepper now
allow all the ingredients to cook under
medium heat for 15 minutes or until the
chicken is cooked through and vegetables
are tender serve warm what I love about
this recipe is that you can use
different meats or beans and pick your
favorite vegetables and it is a one pot
dish that is packed with nutrients plus
you will have less washing to do so each
stuffing has about 343 calories I like
to cook this recipe in bulk and store
the extra in the fridge and warm them up
the next day and they will taste even
better my final favorite is black beans
salsa wrap this recipe does not require
any cooking so if your accommodation
doesn't allow you to cook you can try
this out
the ingredients you'll need are 1 can of
black beans 1 can of corn 1 red bell
pepper chopped 3 tablespoons of salsa
sauce 3 tablespoons of cheese 2 cups of
spinach 1/2 a teaspoon of mixed herbs
and 4 whole grain wraps in a bowl simply
combine the beans corn bell pepper salsa
sauce and season with mixed herbs now
let's assemble it arrange a handful of
spinach then spoon the bean mixture onto
the wrap and I'm going to top mine with
a little bit of shredded cheese roll it
up if you're a vegan you can simply omit
the cheese and to pack more vegetables
into your meal serve it with a side of
salad so this is a curve
by lunch to go and I used to take this
to uni with me each serving has under
300 calories you can even swap the rap
for pita bread or lettuce leaves so
these are some of my favourite lazy
student meals what I use let me know in
the comments below I hope this video
will encourage you to start to eat
better don't be like me when I was a
student okay start to learn to look
after yourself and your body will thank
you
long-term be sure to like this video
share this video on and subscribe to my
youtube channel for a lot more easy lazy
healthy recipes fitness videos and also
fitness tips all the best and start
cooking